Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je vais parler de quelque chose -
un petit mot -
qui concerne à la fois les ingénieurs
et les spécialistes d’éthique comme moi :
le mot « autonomie ».
Je suppose que pour vous,
qui allez être ingénieurs,
l’autonomie est quelque chose de positif.
On essaye de faire des machines autonomes.
Positif aussi en tant qu’individu.
On a eu tout à l'heure Michel, qui nous
a parlé de sa dépendance à la drogue.
C'est un manque d'autonomie.
L’autonomie, c’est la capacité
de s’assumer soi-même.
De même, vous allez faire
des stages, je suppose.
Et l’une des qualités maîtresses
que l’on demande
à un étudiant, futur ingénieur,
qui est en stage,
c’est d’être autonome.
Tout ça laisse entendre
que l’autonomie, c’est positif.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire « autonomie » ?
L’étymologie dit : « auto », soi-même.
« nomos », loi.
L’autonome, c’est celui qui
se donne ses propres lois.
Initialement, le terme s’applique
à une cité, à un pays,
qui n’est pas sous la domination
d’un autre, ni colonisé
et qui peut de soi-même -
On vient d’avoir un exposé
sur la capacité, justement,
que l’on pourrait avoir dans la population
française de se donner ses propres lois.
Le fait qu’on a l’impression que
notre voix est confisquée par d’autres.
Donc vous voyez que l’autonomie
est quelque chose de positif.
Et puis, on peut aller plus loin.
Je vous ai dit que je m’occupais d’éthique
depuis un certain nombre d’années.
À partir du 18e siècle,
les éthiques se fondent
sur l’idée d’autonomie.
Ce sont des philosophes comme
Jean-Jacques Rousseau qui nous disent :
être libre, ce n’est pas faire
n’importe quoi quand on le veut,
parce que dans ce cas-là , on est soumis
à ses désirs immédiats, à ses pulsions.
Non, être libre, c’est choisir soi-même
ses propres lois,
qu’elles ne viennent pas de votre corps,
qu’elles ne viennent pas de l’extérieur,
que ce ne soit pas imposé
par la tradition, par la religion.
Non, vous choisissez vos propres lois
et vous y obéissez.
Donc, l’autonomie, c’est quelque chose,
de ce point de vue-là, de positif.
Mais on va revenir à vous,
et moi aussi, parce que je suis aussi
ingénieur de formation.
L’autonomie, c’est aussi ce qu’on essaye
de donner aux machines
surtout quand on est ingénieur.
C’était une de mes motivations
quand j’ai commencé à faire
de l’intelligence artificielle.
On essaye de faire des machines
qui imitent ce qui est le plus parfait :
imiter un homme,
de faire des machines qui soient capables
de penser comme nous,
d’évoluer comme nous,
bref des machines autonomes.
Et donc l’autonomie,
de ce point de vue-là, c’est positif.
Du moins, on le pense.
Je vais vous donner un premier exemple.
Peut-être que certains d’entre vous seront
engagés à travailler dans ce secteur-là,
celui des voitures autonomes.
Une voiture autonome,
c’est quelque chose de formidable.
On sent bien que c'est l'avenir
de la voiture, c'est le futur.
En plus, c’est formidable
parce que ça permet, lorsqu’on est
dans sa voiture, de faire autre chose.
C’est très ennuyeux de conduire,
donc on peut lire pendant ce temps-là,
ou travailler.
Et puis surtout, c’est formidable
parce qu’on peut espérer que les voitures
autonomes auront moins d’accidents.
Et donc, on va sauver des vies
avec les voitures autonomes.
De ce point de vue-là,
c’est tout à fait positif.
l y a quand même une petite chose
dont vous avez dû entendre parler -
puisqu’on parle d’éthique
sur les voitures autonomes -
c’est que,
à un carrefour, si vous avez un problème,
la voiture doit faire un choix.
Le problème n’est pas lié
directement à l’autonomie,
mais il nous concerne quand même.
Si vous êtes ingénieur
dans votre bureau d’études,
vous travaillez et vous concevez
l’automatisme de la machine.
Vous vous dites : « Supposons
qu’une machine arrive à toute vitesse.
Il y a un feu vert sur un haut de côte,
elle arrive, et là...
il y a un passage protégé.
Il y a cinq personnes, des jeunes
en pleine forme, qui traversent.
La voiture n’a pas le temps de freiner,
elle doit les écraser.
Il y en a au moins trois
qui vont mourir. »
Et là , il y a une solution.
C’est -
quand vous vous calculez -
c’est d’aller sur le côté.
Mais sur le trottoir, malheureusement,
il y a une vieille dame.
Elle est plus âgée.
Le dilemme, c’est de savoir :
est-ce qu’on tue trois personnes
ou est-ce qu’on tue la vieille dame qui
n’a pas du tout traversé au feu vert ?
Toute la difficulté est de savoir
programmer ce genre de choses.
Je ne rentrerai pas dans le détail, il y a
eu énormément d’articles sur ce sujet
et ça inquiète beaucoup
les gens en général.
Et à juste à juste titre, parce que si
vous conduisez, le problème se posera.
Mais ce n’est pas très grave car vous
n’aurez pas le temps de réfléchir à ça.
Là , froidement,
vous allez faire le calcul.
Je ne rentre pas dans le détail,
mais la réalité,
c’est que les accidents de voiture qui
ont eu lieu avec les voitures autonomes
nous ont montré que ce n’était pas
tout à fait ce qui se produisait.
On a eu l’expérience, en mars 2018, d’un
accident qui s’est produit en Arizona.
C’est le fait que la voiture n’arrive pas
à évaluer la situation.
Lorsqu’il y a eu cet accident en Arizona,
la société Uber,
qui avait affrété cette voiture,
s’était dit, pour que la voiture soit
confortable pour les passagers,
qu’ils allaient durcir
les différents critères
car la voiture faisait une embardée
à chaque feuille morte,
ça donnait le mal de mer
et c’était très inconfortable.
Alors ce qu’on a fait, c’est qu’on a dit :
si on ne reconnaît pas les objets devant
mais qu’ils ne sont pas problématiques
on les ignore.
Elle était entraînée pour reconnaître
les piétons, les cyclistes,
les autres voitures, etc.
Là, c’était la nuit, elle avance
et voit quelque chose de bizarre.
Ce n’était ni un piéton ni un cycliste,
c’était une femme qui poussait un vélo.
Peu importe.
Elle l’a écrasée.
Ça montre la difficulté :
ce n’est pas un problème de dilemme,
mais un problème de ce qu’on appelle
en philosophie le jugement.
Pas au sens du jugement judiciaire,
mais comme une opération de l’entendement
qui va vous permettre de catégoriser,
de percevoir la chose.
Mis à part ce détail - ce n’est pas
un petit détail, ce n’est pas facile -
on peut dire que c'est plutôt
positif l'autonomie.
D’accord ?
Maintenant, on va imaginer
quelque chose d’autre.
Les armes.
Les armes autonomes,
ça vous semble positif ?
Non, je pense que vous avez raison,
c’est absolument terrifiant.
Vous avez des espèces
de petits quadcopters
qui ont des petites charges dynamiques,
ils arrivent, ils explosent,
ils choisissent leur cible.
Là, ça fait trop drôlement peur.
Qu’est-ce qui est positif ?
Est-ce que c’est l’autonomie en général
ou y a-t-il certains degrés
d’autonomie qui sont bien ?
On peut se dire : « C’est simple :
les transports, c’est bien.
Et les armes, c’est mauvais. »
Donc on va être pour l’autonomie
des choses qui sont bien
et contre celle des choses
qui sont mauvaises.
D’accord ? Vous me suivez ?
Maintenant, on va prendre quelque chose :
la santé, c’est plutôt bien.
Si vous utilisez
de l’intelligence artificielle
pour faire un système
qui diagnostique des maladies,
est-ce que vous pensez qu’il doit
être complètement autonome ?
On hésite un peu,
on préfère avoir un médecin.
Vous voyez que c’est un tout petit peu
compliqué, cette notion d’autonomie.
Je vous ai parlé de voiture autonome.
C’est bien la voiture autonome,
puisqu’on lui dit qu’on veut aller
à un endroit, elle nous y amène.
Non, non. A supposer que la voiture
soit vraiment autonome
comme l’arme autonome est autonome :
l’arme autonome, elle choisit sa cible -
c’est ça qui nous fout la trouille.
Là, vous dites à votre voiture :
« Il fait beau aujourd’hui, pas très
chaud, mais quand même assez bon.
J’ai envie d’aller à la piscine. »
Et la voiture vous dit :
« Écoutez, j’ai vu que vous aviez
des problèmes de dents
et j’ai pris rendez-vous
avec vous chez le dentiste. »
D’ailleurs, elle vous tutoie, donc :
« Tu vas chez le dentiste. »
Là , vous dites :
« Bon, d’accord, mais... »
Ou alors elle dit :
« Le parking de la piscine est
vraiment très inconfortable.
Donc, j’ai préféré que tu ailles au cinéma
parce que c’est mieux pour moi. »
Est-ce que vous avez envie
d’une voiture autonome comme ça ?
Et là, vous réfléchissez :
« Mais est-ce que c’est bien,
l’autonomie ? »
Ça pose bien sûr un problème.
On va aller même plus loin
parce que l’autonomie des armes,
est-ce que les militaires
veulent des armes autonomes ?
Je suis d’une génération où
on faisait encore son service militaire.
Je l’ai fait d’ailleurs pas loin d’ici,
de l’autre côté de la frontière allemande.
Et j’ai retenu
que les militaires ne voulaient surtout
pas qu’on prenne des décisions soi-même
ni qu’on soit autonome.
Un militaire veut qu’on lui obéisse.
J’ai été interviewé par des militaires
au sujet des armes autonomes.
Ils n’en ont aucune envie.
Vous voyez que les questions d’autonomie
sont des questions un peu délicates.
On peut dire, pour résumer,
qu’il y a des choses dont on pense
qu’elles sont positives,
d’autres qu’elles sont négatives,
mais en général, on pourrait
essayer de condenser les choses
en disant : « On aimerait que
les hommes puissent être autonomes -
puisqu’on voudrait que les machines
nous aident à être autonomes -
et que les machines
soient moins autonomes. »
Pour résumer ce qu’on voudrait
faire avec les machines,
je voudrais vous citer un ouvrage
écrit il y a pas mal d’années.
Il y a eu ensuite une exposition
dessus dans les années 70.
Il a été écrit par Michel Carrouges,
c’est « Les machines célibataires ».
Je trouve que le terme est extrêmement
évocateur de cette idée,
de ce que l’on peut craindre.
Alors, qu’est-ce que c’était ?
Pour lui, c’étaient des œuvres de fiction
qui étaient, lorsque vous les lisez,
totalement autonomes.
C’est exactement
ce qu’on demande à un roman :
que ce soit un univers clos sur lui-même.
C’étaient des machines,
en même temps, extraordinaires.
Je vais vous en citer deux,
mais il y en a plusieurs.
Si vous avez le temps,
je vous engage à les lire.
« Le puits et le pendule »
d’Edgar Allan Poe.
C’est une nouvelle terrifiante.
C’est quelqu’un qui est enfermé, au moment
de l’Inquisition, dans une prison.
Il y a un pendule avec une lame de rasoir.
Elle se balance juste au-dessus de lui,
et il se rend compte
qu’elle descend progressivement.
Elle va descendre, arriver sur lui
et le découper.
Et ce qu’il fait -
je vous donne la solution -
On lui donne juste un peu à manger
pour qu’il continue à vivre.
Il met la nourriture sur les
ficelles qui l’attachent.
Ls rats arrivent,
viennent manger la nourriture,
rongent les ficelles et le libèrent.
Il y a une autre machine effrayante
que vous pouvez lire aussi :
« La colonie pénitentiaire » de Kafka.
Je ne sais pas si vous l’avez lu.
C’est une machine extraordinaire,
ce qu’il ne faut pas faire
quand on est ingénieur.
C’est une machine de torture
vraiment parfaite.
C’est pour -
on a parlé de la loi tout à l’heure -
pour que le prisonnier
intègre totalement la loi.
L’idée, c’est de lui tatouer
les articles de loi sur le corps.
La machine le fait automatiquement,
parfaitement.
Et pour que le prisonnier
vive plus longtemps,
on lui donne du riz automatiquement,
il est nourri pendant des heures.
Il y a cette satisfaction,
cette fascination, devant la machine.
Vous imaginez bien que c’est justement
ce que l’on ne veut pas faire
en intelligence artificielle.
On voudrait justement
des machines qui soient « mariées »,
des machines qui soient sociales,
avec lesquelles on puisse échanger.
On va revenir
sur cette notion d’autonomie.
L’éthique, c’est l’éthique de l’autonomie.
Est-ce que les éthiques doivent toujours
vous aider à être autonome ?
Est-ce que les machines doivent toujours
vous donner toute autonomie ?
En fait, les études rétrospectives
des accidents d’avion montrent quoi ?
Elles montrent que,
pour beaucoup d’entre eux,
l’accident est arrivé parce que
les hommes sont intervenus.
C’est-à-dire que si on avait fait
confiance aux automatismes,
les accidents ne seraient pas advenus.
Ça veut dire que quelquefois,
il faut que les machines soient autonomes
et qu'on ne sollicite pas les hommes.
C’est quand même compliqué, cette affaire.
Est-ce que ça doit être autonome
ou est-ce que ça ne doit pas l’être ?
On va aller plus loin.
On a dit que du point de vue éthique,
effectivement,
il fallait être autonome, entre autres.
La traduction de l’autonomie,
c’est qu’il faut demander aux individus
leur consentement.
Vous avez entendu ces derniers temps,
on a beaucoup parlé de consentement
pour la vaccination.
Justement, lorsqu’on regarde
bien les principes de bioéthique,
est-ce qu’il faut toujours demander
son consentement ?
C’est une question ouverte.
Depuis que des gens dans les années
70, 80, ont écrit sur la bioéthique,
ils ont bien noté qu’il fallait demander
le consentement éclairé
et libre des personnes,
mais qu’il y a des situations
où nous ne sommes pas en mesure
de donner notre consentement.
Par exemple, les enfants en bas âge
ou les personnes qui sont malades.
Ça va me conduire, puisque le thème
du TEDx est « Panser le monde » -
Il ne s’agit pas seulement de penser,
de réfléchir sur le monde,
mais aussi de soigner le monde.
Il y a des éthiques qui ne se fondent pas
seulement sur l’autonomie, sur l’individu.
Penser le monde,
ce n’est pas se penser soi-même,
c’est penser les autres,
regarder les autres.
Effectivement, il y a des éthiques
qui ne sont pas centrées sur le sujet,
mais qui sont centrées
sur l’altérité, le regard vers l’autre.
Ce ne sont plus
des éthiques de l’autonomie,
ce sont ce qu’on appelle
des éthiques de la sollicitude.
Parmi ces études de la sollicitude,
il y a un très grand penseur,
qui s’appelait Emmanuel Lévinas, qui a
beaucoup développé cela en disant que
ce qui est important en éthique,
c’est de regarder l’autre,
de regarder ce qui est
différent dans l’autre,
ce qui fait que l’autre n’est pas
comme nous, mais qu’il est autre,
la radicale différence de l’autre.
Comment perçoit-on
cette différence de l’autre ?
C'est à travers cette chose qui
nous manque tant aujourd'hui.
C’est à travers le visage.
Il dit que le visage,
c’est l’épiphanie de l’autre.
Je vais m’arrêter là mais
je voudrais conclure sur autre chose.
J’ai essayé de parler
du terme d’autonomie,
qui est souvent, en particulier quand
on est ingénieur, assez mal utilisé.
Je vais reprendre une citation
d’un spécialiste du langage, Brice Parain,
mais qui a été beaucoup reprise
et attribuée à tort à Albert Camus,
qu’on a mentionné tout à l’heure.
« Mal nommer les choses,
c’est ajouter au malheur du monde. »
Je crois que nous avons déjà
suffisamment de malheurs aujourd’hui
pour ne pas en rajouter.
Je pense qu’il faut essayer
d’être très précautionneux
lorsqu’on emploie les termes automate,
autonomie, automatisme
et ne pas se tromper.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)